well Skylar for you when you were
presented with the script for cavemen
where do you like you know what there's
there's too many sex scenes family might
be watching my families see me do some
stuff and I do with you know the role
calls for and thankfully the role had so
many redeeming qualities that the and
and by the way like the sex scenes that
are in the movie they're not they're not
a they're not real so that's good be
they're also kind of not perfect they're
not like beautiful at all they're a
pretty dysfunctional and like calm it's
comedy first so I can I loved playing a
moment that has you know levity to it
interesting scenes on set like I mean
are you doing any type of rehearsal time
with these things because you were an
active boy in the film sure you did have
some interesting scenarios so sure do
you to remember any interesting moments
someone said like I don't think I
remember was sleeping in with the enemy
Julia Roberts had everybody take off
their clothes oh yeah yeah three weeks
go go-go-go-go trying and get the
coverage for every scene and trying the
scenes done trying get the day done
there was no time to come up with some
creative way over there was no time for
that there was no like her so I mean we
read through everything but we're not
like when you do a sex scene or
something like that you're not
rehearsing that part of it you know it's
that's for the day like you're not like
hey come over later I have a private
rare like dress rehearsal yeah or
undress rehearsal yeah not the case